[Musique]
souvent les petits
mais gâtés nounours paul parfum patron
talent parfum vous ne serez pas ce que
ça sent bon
ou l'échelle
n'oublie pas de revenir gros gorna
[Musique]
bon
c'est bon 4 x
50 ans
encore une petite cuillère là le pot
moussalaha ne
se conçoit son bon c'est maman qui a
fait des confitures tiens il en reste
encore un petit peu dans l'assiette si
tu veux la butte est bon ce type ont
leur nom maman a dit que les serres
froides et parce que la confiture jeune
sarah malawi un tout petit peu aux gens
qu'un tout petit peu non
non tu n'es pas sérieux
tout type aux noix cette guerre est qu
après c'est plus raisonnable que toi tu
sais maman ne veut pas d'eux comptant
bien l'école a on va chercher maman non
nous je suis gentille maman
je ne mange pas tout et confitures pas
preneur nicolas où êtes vous
[Musique]
le village est à toi je fume je
ne mangerai plus de koffi où j'ai mal au
coeur
je vais prendre
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce pauvre nounours il a été bien puni de
sa gourmandise
nous allons en route au
pourvu que le duo
ne bougez pas trop
ce soir bonne nuit les enfants
faites de boue
[Musique]